[Music]
you would be surprised at the types of
powers that godzilla has had over the
years
from the staple and lovable atomic
breath to actually possessing all the
powers of the famous marvel x-men
at certain times well not actually
having their powers
but his own version of them and at a
very kaiju scale
from 1954 till 2019 we will list down
all of his 20 unique powers
while most of them are awesome and
deadly quite a couple of the powers that
he had in the past
were actually funny so jokes aside here
is the list of all the 20 incredible
powers of godzilla
number one the atomic breath this is the
main and the most used of godzilla's
powers
ever since the 1954 debut godzilla has
always used a version of this deadly
ranged attack
which is when he generates and
manipulates radiation within his body
in a way that allows the g-man to shape
the beam by exhaling
through his mouth at the same time his
spines light up as he gathers up the
energy from his body
and unleashes it upon his foes some
state at the temperature of the
atomic breath to be almost a million
degrees celsius
number two the spiral heat ray this next
power is more extreme
and it's also a version of the atomic
breath but with variations that make it
a unique power
the most evident of these variations is
the fact that there is another set
of beams that spiral alongside main beam
that gives it extra power
enough to even vaporize skies a ghidorah
in godzilla final wars
it was also used three times during the
heisei movie series
once against the ultimate four of
godzilla which is destoroyah
number three the nuclear pulse godzilla
can release a powerful shockwave of
nuclear energy from its entire body
which is useful when he is restrained or
in close combat with a foe
it is similar to a multi-megaton nuclear
weapon
that he uses as a last resort the most
recent usage of this
was in 2019 kotm when godzilla was
fighting king ghidorah
in the final battle and was critically
injured somehow with mothra's essence
and
the human's distraction he was able to
get back up and kill ghidorah with three
of these pulses
number four the dorsal plate and tail
beam this power is only seen in shin
gojira 2016
when this version was under attack from
high up in the air by stealth bombers
shin gojira managed to focus the beams
to shoot out from his dorsal plates
and they are capable of destroying
objects thousands of meters away
around godzilla and are comparable to
his atomic breath and power
unlike the dorsal plate beams though the
tail beam can be fired at the same time
as godzilla's atomic breath allowing him
to strike multiple targets at once
number five the super thermal radiation
particle belt flame
that's long 2016 shin godzilla retains
the trademark atomic breath
but this godzilla signature weapon
initially takes the form of a cloud of
smoke exhaled from his mouth
and then a stream of fire called the
super thermal radiation particle belt
flame
which is capable of burning through the
entire city blocks
at high speed from there he focused the
fire into a narrow
purple radiation heat ray and later
turns back into the flame when his
energy is spent
number six evolution one of godzilla's
most unique abilities is his capacity to
self-mutate
while all other organisms mutate and
evolve gradually over the countless
generations
godzilla has the ability to mutate his
dna at will
to adapt to any situation while his
ability to mutate depends on every movie
or series he is in
he was seen to mutate very fast in shin
gojira and was able to grow bigger with
bigger dorsal plates
and the monster was as well as evolving
against weapons
as seen in godzilla earth
number 7 regeneration godzilla can
regenerate extremely quickly
if injured just like deadpool from
practically any wound including being
completely disintegrated or blown to
bits and pieces
godzilla's regeneration is due to a
substance in his cells known as
the organizer g1 which has proven to be
highly mutagenic
to other creatures such as biollante and
orga in more recent movies though
his speed of regeneration is slower
owing to the fact that the producers
wanting to be more realistic
number 8 psychic abilities one of his
less known powers is his very high
mental ability
and telepathy as well as blocking other
psychics from taking over his mind
godzilla is said to be the most powerful
psychic in the world and is able to
sense danger or the exact location of
where he needs to be at any time
godzilla was able to telepathically
communicate with godzilla junior
and locate him wherever he is so yeah
he is also the professor xavier of the
kaiju
not just their deadpool
number nine radio activity godzilla is a
nuclear power plant and is very unstable
at times
he was prone to meltdown more than once
and even caused his death in the events
of godzilla vs destroyer
the levels of radiation godzilla emits
is enough to render cities unlivable
if he was there for a long time but
fortunately his radio activity is
short-lived
in the most verse it is said that the
radiation of the titans including
godzilla
was actually reviving lost ecosystems so
here
it is a good power unlike the other
times
number 10 melee combat like any predator
godzilla will sing his sharp teeth and
claws into an enemy's flesh
when in close combat he can also use his
sharp dorsal planes
on his back to cut through an enemy or
slice off an enemy's limb
he also uses his powerful tail as a
bludgeoning weapon against enemies
godzilla's tail is incredibly strong
even
being able to support his entire weight
and allow him to slide
on and deliver a super flying kick
which is something that we all want to
forget actually
number 11 flight the iconic kaiju is
obviously known for stomping through
cities and destroying everything in its
path
in the godzilla movies but in the film
godzilla vs hidora
he actually tried something new he
freaking
took into the air and flew like an
oversized anti-aerodynamic rocket using
his atomic breath as
a trust and even curl up like a ball to
avoid the tail from touching the ground
these are one of the goofy powers that
godzilla once
had and will never be shown again
hopefully
number 12 magnetism another one of the
funny powers of godzilla is this one
the powers of magnetism hang on we will
get to the serious powers again but
let's dive into the time
when he fought mechagodzilla and
suddenly started to attract metal
towards him
which means unfortunately the maker
godzilla
that was trying to fly away as well was
attracted to him
even godzilla earth showed that its
cells are like micro super magnets that
form a very powerful electromagnetic
field
but it was not as goofy as the 1974
magneto
godzilla number 13
super durability godzilla's height is
nearly indestructible and is not damaged
at all by any conventional weapons
allowing him to withstand heavy gunfire
tank shells rockets missiles
and even blows from other monsters with
impressive resistance
and even nuclear weapons godzilla can
survive being completely submerged in
magma
and in ground zero of a meteorite impact
very few of godzilla's opponents can
pierce godzilla's skin
and draw blood godzilla has also taken
on two
miniature black holes before and survive
number 14 energy absorption godzilla has
a remarkable capacity for
absorbing various energy godzilla
naturally feeds on radiation but
can also draw power from plasma or
electricity godzilla was also able to
absorb the life force of rodan and be
completely revitalized enough to destroy
super mecha godzilla
godzilla also once displayed the ability
to absorb enemy attacks
and project the energy back at the
source using his atomic breath
he was also able to absorb mothra's
essence in order to transform into
burning godzilla in kotm
number 15 super stamina and indomitable
will
godzilla also possesses an utterly
insane level of stamina allowing him to
physically exert himself
for several hours without getting tired
or winded godzilla has fought more than
one enemy at a time and although being
overpowered at certain battles
he comes back to finish the battle with
the same level of energy although his
opponents
have lost their stamina and even against
unsurmountable odds or
death he goes on to finish the fight
which is a praise to his will power
number 16 his amphibiosity godzilla has
an amphibious lifestyle spending most of
his life in water
and other times in land godzilla can
breathe underwater and sleeps in the
ocean depths for as long as he wants
being a carnivore in earlier films he
was said to have feasted on the meat of
wales
godzilla's even fought opponents in
water often he excels far better in
fights underwater than on land
he is the poseidon of the titans as seen
when he easily overpowered ghidorah in
kotm
number 17 the oscillatory wave
godzilla's earth's
roar can literally shake air and produce
powerful shock waves with high
oscillatory frequency destroying targets
with resonance phenomena
despite being a shock wave generated by
sound it's precise being able to direct
strike targets from nearly a half a mile
away or even a mile away
according to official information this
attack can crush the substance
to the molecular level by resonant
destruction due to the very powerful
electromagnetic waves
number 18 the electromagnetic pulse much
like the mutos from godzilla this
incarnation of godzilla which is
godzilla earth
is able to generate and discharge an emp
when shooting his iconic beam
the emp is strong enough to destroy any
normal electronics
including cars and shelters instantly
and even specialized electronics for
military usage
alongside the pulse his body also
generates a very powerful
electromagnetic field
which forms into an electromagnetic
shield that is asymmetrically permeable
which means it is one way
number 19 electromagnetic shock wave
another one of
godzilla earth's powers is when he
concentrates the powerful plasma from
his fins
into his tail and produces a plasma
blade extending for
hundreds of meters that reduces anything
attaches to ash
and during the use of his plasma tail
blade a single swipe of its tail
surpassing the speed of sound
produces a powerful electromagnetic wave
a shock wave
that can wipe out vast areas surrounding
godzilla
and number 20 the alpha call although
technically not a physical power or
something that can be used to destroy
or affect anything physically this alpha
call of the monster verse version of
godzilla was able to command respect
from the other titans
slash kaiju of that universe the alpha
call of godzilla kept the titans in
check for thousands of years
and until another call the one of
ghidorah was sounded
did the other titans awaken but then
again in the end they bowed down again
to the king of the monsters
and so with that we come to the end of
the video
please leave a thumbs up for support and
also do support our channel by
subscribing for updates
and while you're at it smash that
notification bell for regular
notifications
or for our monster and guide you videos
and also do comment